Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Karen cousins from marina fires sitting
in for David Packman today.
Uh, we had a pretty busy Monday.
Obviously lots of bad news coming out for
Donald Trump and lots of things Donald Trump
did that he thought were going to make his
life so much easier, but in fact, they're
really just going to make it a living nightmare.
And one of those things was that the DOJ ordered
former White House counsel Don McGahn to not
comply with a congressional subpoena.
Then Don McGahn, through his attorneys, made
it clear to Congress that he was not going
to be showing up today Tuesday or the hearing
that they wanted to have.
He wasn't going to give his testimony because
the DOJ told him not to comply.
That is called, um, obstruction folks.
You can't do that.
You're suborning that.
That's exactly what just happened with Don
McGahn.
Democrats obviously want the opportunity to
speak to don McGahn because according to the
Mueller report, McGann played a central role
in telling Mueller and the investigators about
potential obstruction of justice on behalf
of the president of the United States.
This is obstruction that McGann claims Donald
Trump committed or was involved directly in.
So Democrats rightfully want to know more.
They need some more answers on this.
They need to see if there was intent to obstruct
justice because if there was, then they absolutely
100% could move forward with articles of impeachment
against the president based on obstruction
of justice.
Now, don't get me wrong, they're already sitting
on a plethora of information on which they
could impeach the president, but they want
more.
They want to make it foolproof.
They want to hit him with all of the charges
that they possibly could, which is completely
unnecessary.
I you look at the poll numbers right now,
a majority of people do think that the Mueller
report made Trump look worse, made it seem
like he did commit some kind of crime.
That crime is likely obstruction of justice.
Don McGahn got subpoenaed.
He is still also a lawyer with the Jones Day
law firms, so it would be interesting to know
what Jones Day has to say about one of their
own lawyers disregarding a subpoena thinking
that they are above the law.
You can't ignore a subpoena folks.
I mean, let's get that out of the way right
now.
If you get subpoenaed, you are legally obligated
to show up and the House of Representatives
does have a mechanism to force this.
They subpoenaed McGann.
He said, I'm not showing up.
They can send the sergeant at arms to go and
arrest him, throw him in the little bitty
jail that they have right there at the House
of Representatives until he agrees to testify.
They have the authority and the power to do
that, but they're not going to, and that's
the most disappointing thing out of all of
this is that they're not going to do just
going to set up yet a another legal battle
against the president.
The Democrats are likely going to win just
like they're winning the other ones, but time's
a factor, right?
Or they've got what, 18 months, 18 months
before the election, and if they lose their
majority in that election, it's not likely,
but it is possible obviously then suddenly
any talk of impeachment is out the window.
It will never happen at that point.
So rather than having to send this to court,
get the courts to enforce it, they'll side
with the Democrats.
Then the president appeals and appeals until
he gets all the way to the supreme court.
That could take more than 18 months.
And I know based on some of the other cases
that we have already seen, the judges typically
do expedite these, but we can't guarantee
something like that would happen every single
time.
Especially when you have a White House filing
a lawsuit or Democrats filing a lawsuit at
every possible opportunity.
Use the mechanisms you have in place, throw
them again in your tiny little jail and wait
for him to start singing because Mcgann's
made it clear he actually did want to testify,
but he's kind of between a rock and a hard
place.
He thinks that it's best to listen to the
president rather than listening to Congress.
He seems to forget that at the end of the
day, Congress has just as much, if not more
in this particular situation, power than the
president does and they can make his life
hell if they choose to do so.
And I think at this point it's time for them
to choose to do so.
Not just because of McGann's testimony either,
but to send a message, it's time to tell this
White House that you are not above the law,
that your administration officials are not
above the law.
And that when this branch of the government
that has the responsibility of oversight of
the executive branch comes calling, you have
to pick up the phone.
You don't have a choice.
Unfortunately, leadership in the House of
Representatives right now is at least giving
the appearance of being exceptionally weak.
Not saying they are exactly week, but by not
impeaching they're coming across as weak.
They may have some kind of grand strategy
that we don't know about.
They may be playing a longer game.
They may have an ace up their sleeves that
we don't even know exists, but by not knowing
those things, it makes them look weak.
It makes them look like they were afraid.
I mean, we've heard them say that, oh, the
public doesn't support impeachment.
Who Cares?
The public didn't support bailing out the
big banks, but you did that anyway.
The public didn't support the Republican tax
scam, but they did that anyway.
The public didn't support the Republican's
healthcare plan two years ago, but they tried
to do that anyway, since when does public
opinion actually weigh on the minds of members
of Congress?
You guys every day do stuff that the public
says, that's a bad idea.
We want this instead.
You never listened to them.
And then on this one issue where you shouldn't
listen to them, you're using the public as
an excuse to not go forward with it.
Just do it.
That's it.
There's no questioning this.
There's no being mealy mouth.
There's no being wishy washy.
This needs to happen not just to get McGann's
testimony, but to restore some sense of order
and accountability
to Congress.